- I gave mon--
(burping)
- What the--
- What the fuck was that?
- That burp just slipped out.
(upbeat dance music)
- Live and direct from Hollywood
- We are here at Busby headquarters
about to go on the ultimate--
- Nacho Cheese adventure.
- We're gonna start off at one nacho place
- Then we're gonna ask
the people who work there
if they weren't to eat at their own place,
where would they get nachos?
- And so on, and so on,
and so on until we get
to the best nacho joint in L.A.
- And everyone's gonna have
diarrhea at the end of the day.
- We've got our five categories.
The crunch, the toppings
, the looks, the cheese
and the drunk factor.
How good would these nachos be
when you've had a few too many?
And we're doing this whole
tour in my nacho wagon.
- He did not paint his
truck for this video.
His truck is always looking that stupid.
There's no air conditioning so just...
- We're eating nachos!
(laughs)
- So we're heading to Buffalo Wild Wings.
This is Ryan here's favorite nacho spot.
- It's just my favorite spot.
- I want one of these.
- Do you guys accept vertical IDs?
- Oh my god! You don't need to card him.
Let's be honest, come
on, look at his face.
- You can cheers that water, Steven.
- Aw, geeze.
(laughter)
(all chanting "nachos")
- Whoo, yeah!
- Can I say that this looks
like very clean nachos?
- [Colin] Yeah, looks super clean, yeah.
- This is like the L.A. nacho.
(chips crunch)
- Fire, that's fire!
The queso is fresh.
- Everything's super fresh.
- They break really
easy, which we all know,
in nachos, when your chips
break, that's the biggest bummer.
- I'm giving crunch a seven.
(chip crunches)
- 10.
- 10? Holy (beep) you love these chips!
- Look at these chunks of chicken.
They're huge.
I can appreciate that.
- Do they even have guac in here?
- There's no guac or sour cream.
- I thought they did.
This is how much I
remember my Buffalo trips.
- Yeah, I'm gonna go five on the toppings
because there's no guac, no
sour cream and that's huge.
- You're harsh Ryan. It's your spot.
- Now for drunk factor.
I don't want healthy-ass
nachos when I'm drunk.
I'm going with four.
- On the plus side, though,
you eat healthy-ass nachos
when you're drunk, the Dads
won't be that bad tomorrow.
- Dads?
- I am slightly--
- Day after drinking (bleep)
I'm giving them a seven.
- Wait, have you ever been drunk before?
- I have never been drunk before.
- Ooh, wait a minute!
- We'll do a speculative
box. We'll put a cloud on it.
- No no no no no!
I get a real rating!
- Put quotes around his number.
- Oh yeah.
- Put this as a 10.
Got 139 out of 200.
- Whoa!
- That's like a C, right?
I would know 'cause I
dropped out of three colleges
and I always got C's.
- I love bar nachos. Bar
nachos are pretty amazing.
If not I would maybe say Big Wings,
there's one in North Hollywood.
(upbeat techno music)
- I am mediocrely satisfied.
- Cheers!
- I'm startin' to sober up here. Cheers.
Oh my god.
And you know what?
(chip crunches)
Oh god!
- I grabbed my beer so quick.
I was like, no, my beer!
- Look at the seasoning on this chip.
- And this cheese is
gonna be a little firmer,
a little more to deal with.
- There's too much crunch.
- Negative three, give that a seven.
- It's like a layer of toppings.
I would've liked the toppings
spread out a little bit.
- You know what, I agree with you.
- 'Cause look, it's like chip, blank chip.
- You just threw the chip on the table.
- Blank chip.
- It looked great. I
give that bad boy a 10.
- When you're drunk you
need that sloppiness.
This is just, you know, it's very dry.
- All in all, not the worst nachos,
but let's get a total on this, Steve.
- Final score is, wow you
guys are so intent on this.
154.
- If you could not eat the
nachos here at Big Wings,
where would you go?
- I would go to El Compadres
on Sunset right here.
- There's a bean at the bottom of my beer.
- Uncle Colin's had a little too much
of Grandma's cough medicine, so.
(laughter)
Our intern has to drive us now.
Don't crash my car.
- Okay.
(upbeat dance music)
- I'm pretty confident that these nachos
are gonna be the the best we've had today
because we're at like
a real Mexican joint.
- Granted, nachos aren't
a traditional Mexican food
but I do think these'll be the most
What in the world is going
on right here? (laughs)
- Whoa!
- Alright, so this is
how nachos need to look.
- Look at Ryan's face.
- I gotta make sure it's good.
- Jesus man.
- What do we say, Steven?
- This is ridiculous!
- Alright, that is a Hot 10 right there.
- Hot 10.
- The guac is so fresh.
- So fresh!
- Oh my god!
- Like it grew in the
backyard two days ago.
- I would choose this over sex any day.
- Absolutely.
- I still like sex, but I
think these are good nachos.
(laughter)
It's just like it's a perfect mix
of the stretchy and gooey--
- I think we all agree, it's 10.
- I'm gonna go nine, just
'cause I don't wanna be--
- Oh my god!
- Steve--
- Just 'cause I wanna be annoying.
- This is why no one likes you.
(laughter)
- The reason why we're
all giving this tens
is not because we're drunk
because these nachos are amazing.
- [Both] So good.
- Drunk factor?
- I don't know much about drinking,
but I gotta give this like a three.
It's too fancy of a restaurant to like--
- Oh my god Steve!
- To be going ham at drinks.
- We're drinking flaming margaritas.
- You're gonna ruin their score--
- Be a team player goddammit!
- Three.
- Oh my god!
- Yeah, their final score is 189!
- I'm full of nachos
and margaritas and beer
and Quasi, don't be too heavy
on the gas on the way home.
(all rapping beats)
♫ I'm a little gross, makin'
melt in my mouth like butter
♫ I'm toast, hey